big industrial inventions in the 21st
century made by research and development
teams enormous corporations they don't
come out of somewhere like this a
traditional workshop and foundry that
can still be powered by steam sitting in
a rural town in Australia and yet a
screw is a very simple machine it takes
rotational motion and turns it into
linear motion so you can rotate this
screw the stuff down there will get
picked up and friction will stop it
falling down again right away that's
called a vertical screw conveyor and
you'll find something like this in
factories around the world for lifting
and moving but powder or grain or sand
what would happen if instead of rotating
the screw you instead kept it still and
just rotated this cylinder around it
my guess when someone showed me this was
well nothing the cylinder will just
rotate in place it's just a a cylinder
with a couple of scoops at the bottom
if you're confused by that subs I the
Owls name came from Cornwall my
grandfather came out in 1868 at 18 years
of age dad made his first engine a steam
engine in 1906 when he was 16 1925 my
older brother was born he's still going
and I came along in 1930 we served an
apprenticeship under our father I'm
officially where from when we were kids
we try to keep up with the times as much
as we can but using traditional methods
just before Christmas I think 2003 we
had this new mixer that we'd bought it
was $21,000 Henry had it set up where we
were going to use it
nothing seemed suitable for the
elevation of the sand up to the hopper
over the top of the machine and I woke
one morning 3 o'clock in the morning
with this crazy idea and made a sketch
of it and went back to bed and went
sleep and the next day I came to work
and I said I've had a thought about
making this and that one works I said
and I said well again I thought it was
only a matter of days or a week and we
had the first little machine operating
we drove it with an electric drill we
said about making a decent machine then
and we put it in a foundry it did the
job amazing people were coming to have a
look at it and I realized we should put
a patent application in order this was
so different I sought to be easily
protected because rotating the casing
instead of the screw you can see that
it's different we spent a lot of money
on Payton coverage and the name holes
elevator hood being applied to it
they're made in America and Holland and
France and Spain you name it with this
elevator it's a full flow and there's no
movement of air virtually except what
might be between the particles of sand
so there's really no dust generated by
the machine only where it falls back
through the open air this is also a very
important thing where you're handling
dusty explosive materials corn dusters
highly explosive sugar big explosion in
USA a few years back in the demolished
refinery their clearance between the
inside of the rotating tube and the
screw allows product to go through it
and not be damaged not crushed it's a
very forgiving type of machine because
it can be in very poor condition or
it'll work it's been found that it's a
more accurate volumetric feeder than a
lot of the devices that they use this
took a while to get my head around
visually rotating the cylinder instead
of the screw is very different but from
a physics perspective it's really not if
you rotate the screw it looks like each
level in there is moving upwards but
that's just an illusion it's just
rotating horizontally stuff gets lifted
because as the screw rotates the
particles at the top of the pile shoved
out of the way and they prefer to take
the easy route upwards through air
instead of pushing the heavy bulk below
out of the way when you rotate the
cylinder exactly the same thing is
happening the buckets underneath force
the particles to go somewhere and when
they're pushed into the screw they take
the easy route up through air and the
next ones do the same in the next one in
the next from the next one everything
keeps going up they're taking the easy
path it is counter intuitive and look I
am trying to not make this be an
infomercial I checked yeah this is being
used all over the world now from food
handling to solar power towers this is a
good new way of lifting bulk stuff so
what I really don't understand this
through the 20th century a century of
industrialization and automation how did
no one spot this earlier I don't know
why somebody else hasn't ornament in USA
calling we are for me it is - it's
different as useful and if it helped
people well that's great thank you to
Peter olds and all the team and olds
engineering you can find out more about
them and about the old elevator at the
link in the description
I am gonna have to give you a hand
clearing up this birdseed